let me just say before we even continue
that my ear
[ __ ] hurts i know uh presumably this
will come out
after we've both posted footage of the
pooh cannon
which is something i just dreadfully
failed to think through
i don't know what i put i just put my
ear there
i mean dude i dialed up the psi
pounds per square inch is that what it
is yeah dude
i died i did we filled up a poo cannon
and
blasted my ear and it just straight
rocked my eardrum and filled my
ear canal with dog [ __ ] with wendy's
poop
yeah wendy among three other dogs four
different dogs were in the blind oh wow
yeah so where's that video gonna play or
where is it playing as we speak
is gonna put it on his youtube vlog and
i'm gonna put it on my
youtube blog i sent it to my girl she
says dude
save this for something bigger than
youtube and i said
yeah well this was with the milk boys
like
pretty big pretty pretty worth it it's
bigger than youtube yeah
super worth it to go big oh [ __ ]
you keep doing that right now it's like
when you're like the
you do the pressure change you know like
it's just really sensitive in there too
so the doctor didn't say that like you
know there's a lot of poop they were
like there's a lot of wax well the thing
the thing that bummed me out was it was
a physician's assistant and i'm not
talking [ __ ] about physicians assistants
but like
they're not doctors that's what the old
guy was because this thing said
physician's assistant
so i'm like maybe we should go see a
doctor open-minded
to going to uh a proper doctor because
again
it is pretty messed up can i just tell
you how [ __ ] up my new tour
is it's completely multimedia
legitimately x-rated
there's legal waivers all over the venue
because i'm actually worried about
getting sued
and i don't give a [ __ ] man because it's
gnarly and it's all the stuff i wasn't
allowed to do on jackass
so get to my [ __ ] website stevo.com
and get your tickets man especially with
this movie coming out dude
they're all gonna sell dude so hurry up
while you can get seats